let's take one more call if we have it
the number is 6 1 7 8 30 for 750 name
and where you're calling from hi I'm
David call from Oregon dan from Oregon
pleasure having you on what can we do
for you today I'd like you to comment on
the ID I've seen on the internet that
the big corporations have kind of stolen
you know the government's and democracy
and taken over what do you think about
that idea it's a very broad question did
that they could be approached a couple
of different ways do big corporations
have disproportionate lobbying power
immunity from following the the laws is
written the ability to sort of create
new infrastructures like what TPP would
do with these transnational sort of
jurisdictions for for for deciding on
corporate malfeasance of course the
answer is yes right i mean has citizens
united and the the reductions on
restrictions for donations given
corporations disproportionate power of
course the answer is yes i mean it that
then it becomes more conspiratorial
right uh to what extent do individual
ceos manipulate elected officials i mean
through lobbying you can certainly make
the case that the wants and desires of
big corporations are having an impact in
Washington we know that when you look at
the biggest contributors uh look at the
industry they're the biggest
contributors to elected officials and
then you see how legislation is
regularly past that is better for those
types of businesses businesses in
particular industries that are big
donors oil farm us so many others the
insurance industry how can you argue
that corporations don't have a big and
and aggressive grasp on our government I
mean is that the type of thing you're
asking about yes how we fall into like a
weird oligarchy thing do you think I
mean it's not as far as Alex Jones said
I don't know but we had this in the
words you might have Alex Jones way over
here and on the other side you've got
someone who thinks corporations have no
power there is a Princeton study which
says we are effectively in an oligarchy
in the United States the policy desires
and
she's of the rich and big corporations
are disproportionately more likely to
eventually make it into and become law
in the United States and that that's
just the reality and the only way to
explain that away without saying there's
something wrong is to say it's not that
the rich and corporations are getting
what they want because they donate a lot
of money they're getting what they want
because they just have better ideas and
I think you and I Dan know that they're
there can't possibly be truth to that in
the in the grand scope can there yes
another kid all right very very good
idea try progestin yet dan from Oregon
thanks so much for the call that is
going to do it for calls this week we
will take more calls next week 6 17 8 30
for 750 is the number to call we'll take
a break and be back with plenty more
after this